Paxton Forrest busy tomorrow so foxy
forest it's the sixth amidst an action
platformer with RPG past elements and
the caution is we can seamlessly switch
between two three to find season 11 -
okay so that way no level fits the same
once it's like spring to winter and
winter to trust the water once it's like
from spring to fall on the fall giant
leaves will fall down to the caduceus
platforms we have a stage where the
forest is on fire in summer and you can
switch to fall and wayne will come up to
finish the flames so that the seasons
going on yes tell me about the
characters are part of the carrot yes
Rick the Fox is like a Lord nor the
anti-hero can you stop
now his weapons and magic mannequins
politics oh that's very unique because
mr. met Stella crossbone he can do
ranged attacks to those architects of
the Anakin ahsoka master seasons so
there's so much of this gameplay we got
Laura attic right here the bill that
he's playing some boxing for us right
now game looks at a club great classic
boomers 8 16-bit field on the
supernintendo viable feeling I see I see
the energy Super Nintendo alright so on
what's going on right now this is one of
the opening robbers between yes then we
do
[Music]
short short fire
[Laughter]
okay let's
the mana reduction because
Nihad that's detect motions now where
this currency where were Indonesian to
able use astrology at the doughnut shop
in name
to the past
now these flowers are children is that
that bottle right okay
Oh
reproduction one
Oh
[Laughter]
because exactly
Oh successful
the biggest question was is there co-op
with a planning for an estimate read
Bosnia but said you ran out of time
oh good ideas so no more no more but
also just for the record we process
there's no controversy between the other
game is the two parts games can exist
[Laughter]
this looks great classic feel attic how
you feel about a baby italics is lovely
you can
that's pretty cool that's a very unique
mechanic well this which exceeds
pretty cool no I mean actually a lot
attic questions do you guys have any
boss fights yes we have very cool boss
but if you gave me this feeling
look at this market and report for spots
- awesome more fights one attic she'll
be happy
look at this oh wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
watch us get this far any of these s to
the far right here
annika Patty has a question it's not
like this is crazy but yet the freezes
freeze it they jump up and said then you
have to unfreeze it yes they can go it's
very cool I did it earlier
different never why not session let's
write every level as you know do you
have a plan
[Music]
our South article of logs out everything
that you need for season
now as long as the engine itself but
input into our using it anymore design
self-contained engine is done
no actually this is unity you were these
back in building huh we keep hearing
about unity it's been great for us
because it's really easy to pause the
game so we always have to be back in
mind who was wants to come on the
consoles as well as community
next on PC PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
and the switch and switch now that's
also I think this is be personally an
amazing neighborhood switch also amazing
a permit for the major platforms as well
now as far as the arm the switch while
we're getting the same time release yes
nice I'm man alright so this month might
be the shot just by those strikes as we
shot yes all right mom yeah and if
enough talk about we forgot it down do
you like it if there's a boss on this
one you see NORAD's asking if there's a
boss that began to go back to the world
but please go back the world map and we
want to get one boss fight if you can
curious
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
there's no way to dad switch guys he
said
[Music]
in the dual Google just help us out make
pickle or daddy look good
my xbox pouch on you like that
[Music]
okay Tendo
- market Oh
to help the Lord's out
now over that far in the middle after
that's decreasing right
[Music]
detective mouse when I think you got too
much
I worked once we handle yourself
the projectiles
and then use it for just now all they
way from to come down to is very long
the mechanic reason present-day suitable
yeah
[Music]
to help us noobs like us I need ammo
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Tara's chickens beginning
yes we do
the bride that's right
what does he have in the back
- look like you're feeling that it was a
good game baby I said here we go
you find the realm of the Lord's name so
enthusiastic he is the Lord is a box
impartial yes please come out this lease
against this game at least we know again
next month's may on PC PlayStation 4
Xbox one Anthony chadway
closer we get to we will
one thing we'll get tomorrow we have so
many other games that we're going to get
to and then let me see how we're gonna
cut the screen up again toll on the uber
can absolutely thank you so much say
game thank you so much